because it's previewing fine okay all
right it says rely does it look like
we're live now I just I'm gonna I'll
give you guys the link here this is live
now we are that's Mike is it is it the
same is it the same time it's so it's no
yeah it's working
we're alive Oh drives me crazy
YouTube's driving me crazy
anyhow well everyone about our intros
and hellos I'll just do it real quick
just in case something has broken run
table de stream team that was us hello
welcome yes thanks for there you go
thank you she is with us and she's gonna
tell us how she's become a content
creator for you know all of her
different avenues or the podcast YouTube
all that fun stuff
we have MJ as a boss here what's poppin
there we go we got it so I got it once
out of here today I'm happy and miss
l-boogie is with us also what's poppin I
think we're gonna have to start a
drinking game every single time I say
the word family oh yeah because I real
issen to it last week and I was just
like I've said it way too many so I
should take her Friday night drinking I
don't think you're gonna have enough
liquor for that one but yes apparently
it is my it's my downfall and I am so
now though here also Lord P because
nobody can ever pronounce or find my
name and I am here helping you know
facilitate this so as we've all come
here to speak to everybody we are here
for it's a Lila HD so please tell us how
you decided to start becoming a content
creator and what what kind of puts you
into that type of realm of what you
Wow so my story is is what's interesting
about is very kind of lengthy because I
was doing like content creation and
podcasting before it became big on like
YouTube and I feel like if I were to
stuck with it probably be something
really big today but I kind of gave up
several times and switched jobs and real
life happened but I started back in the
day as a writer for a website called
Xbox gamers calm which was for the OG
xbox mhm
I just was always been passionate about
it because I mean I've been playing
video games since I was 4 and um while I
was writing on that particular website
people would always comment like oh you
know we like your your writing you
should do your own thing since you know
we was having some issues with the owner
he was he couldn't decide what he wanted
to keep going with it or not so I kind
of spun off and did my own website
called on the Xbox calm and then at the
time well during that time I met another
guy at a convention that I went to and
he was doing a website call 360 style
Dannette which was like all about
backgrounds doing like you know art for
them and you know if anyone know me they
know I'm a designer or and I started
like graphics and things like that back
in that during that time and so I would
do work for him I became a developer for
that site and this was all like early
2000s so I would say 2003 to like 2007
or so was when all that kind of took
place but since 2007 I had start I
switched from doing all of that to doing
a website called g3 XCOM which would do
like designs for ready so idea Lexie of
Thieves a dick Euler instinct recore
punching all the designs on there's
pretty much under that umbrella that I
created and then after that I created a
bunch of like you know phone apps for
gaming so I did one under the digital or
umbrella and I've been using that pretty
much as a portfolio to do other things
but most recently I would say I started
doing videos
YouTube just under the D delilah HD
monitor I figured I want to focus more
on myself I said I'm just playing the
background for all these other
successful sites that did really great
things and so I was like you know I'm
gonna focus on me and try to do things
for myself um and so that's how that
started back and I would say 2016-2017 I
mean I started doing like one video a
week started posting up gameplay talking
about games talk about things that was
just coming out soon researching
developers and stuff and I just kinda
never fully flushed that out and it was
like late I would say 2017 I was kind of
a little bit bummed because you know
Microsoft I was going through a lot of
their transitioning they started no
closed the studios and so being a your
primary Xbox you know platform covering
just that the content particularly was
just like I had no more enthusiasm to
kind of focus on that so then I was like
man what do you know what I don't know
what I'm gonna do and that's always kept
talking about like I'm retiring from it
all I'm not gonna do anything I'm gonna
just focus on my career focus on work
and lo and behold I run into like
growing me gaming with meeting with like
you know l-boogie doesn't make a long
story short just meeting with like
l-boogie lady and Charisse so that's
kind of where I'm at now just you know
doing things with growing the gaming and
you know you just Dylan down and
thinking about whether I want to
continue with doing a YouTube channel I
still do the like Xbox win campaign
which is you know something I started a
long time ago you know along with these
sites I had did back in the day so we're
like I give away $60 to three inch
dollars per quarter for like people who
just I'm just randomly because I just
always like giving things away it was
pretty fun um that's pretty much it just
to make a long story short so so you
said throughout your career kind of as
its evolved and changed so so you'd say
you're your normal I hate to work this
way but a normal professional like your
you you are a I'm a designer
I'm a designer I'm a I'm a UI designer
for developing developer tools Microsoft
so and you've used that kind of that
knowledge it's like I've used like you
know everything that I'm kind of done in
the past it's like a launchpad for the
jobs I've been able to get up into this
point it's always been kind of gaming
related well cuz I've always been
dispassionate about it I've been playing
since I was four though as far as it
just kind of give up on gaming in
general but but yeah it's it's been my
lifeblood speaker it's been the passion
that you've wanted to pursue your whole
entire life that's right that's exactly
right I feel that's most of most of our
generation of people who are podcasters
and gamers that want to be in the gaming
sphere being a developer or a writer or
something in that in that realm I mean I
look for MJ I know I was going to school
and he's gonna he's pursuing something
like that I know I'm I know that I want
to be in that type of sphere but I I you
know I'm getting my itch scratch so to
speak but helping the the Lords are
given that net team do their thing and
iron low Spock has seemed another thing
so at least that that's where I get my
scratch you know my scratching for a
first yeah I could say the the road
itself it hasn't been easy because I
mean I was having been to like eighty
threes and it's like every time I go I
meet a different set of people with the
depending on like what interesting the
end we're coming to work for and you'll
be surprised just who doesn't remember
you who does so it's all about just
keeping those relationships tight and
definitely utilizing those to your
advantage
I mean that's why I recommend people to
go all the time so yeah if you really
want to get into the space I would say
always always always have a fantastic
portfolio know how to talk to talk walk
the walk and keep your relationships
tight now how did you end up meeting up
with l-boogie and Cherise and in the end
the rest of the the gwg ladies oh sure
so that I would say this was
like 2017 I believe it was the consul
corner podcast and one of the ladies on
the show she was trying to do it all
ladies panel and I've always been very
vocal on Twitter about like gaming
things and so she just kind of reached
out to me was like I'm doing this
podcast I really would like for you to
be a guest and I was okay you know
I'll try it out and I think when I went
in that show I think lady was was also
on that show a couple in a couple other
women we were all just kind of talking
about games and this was ran by I
believe it was shewolf
it's what they wear moniker was when it
was called console corner and we would
just talk about games and things like
that
I remember lady reached out to me just
like Delilah you know I really I want to
do my own podcast and I was like man
look I'm retired I'm done I I don't want
to do any shows so but if I might do
something you know it's like all or
nothing with me like I always try to go
like I try to put my best foot foot
forward on everything that I attempt so
that's like we really gonna do this
this got we got to be consistent and you
know you can't just be something we
stopped a star and it's like you know I
didn't want to just try and and give up
and stop again so um I was talking with
her she's like okay well let me let me
I said plus I don't want to just be you
and me I feel like we need a bigger team
I said let me ask around for somebody
that can kind of assist us and she was
like well I may have somebody in mind I
think she reached out to boogie and I
think they met up or something like that
I'll know that whole story but you can
probably tell I started better than I
could and then pretty much after I
reached out to a close friend of mine
and well Cherise and she reached out to
l-boogie that was pretty much you know
that was it that was the four of us and
we just kind of been doing it ever since
so you Uli's have just passed your
hundredth episode yep so how did how did
that make you feel
have you that you actually accomplished
a hundred episodes because that's that's
a big deal you know
yeah not something that you didn't it's
not I would say like when people are
like oh I've been doing a podcast I
don't you
Oh how many have you done there like
I've done seven and it's like that's not
really considered like a full podcast
you're still in your baby stages but now
you've hit that hundred I bet that's
that VAT is like a well-established
podcast and in my book and I've been in
in your channel live a few times and I
think that Uli's do an amazing job with
everything now where do you get where do
you ladies get your gameplay from and
who thought who thought of that as your
type of method of doing the podcast
itself
Wow I think that's actually because we
you know after doing the console corner
we actually lady and I went on grg which
was a separate it's a separate podcast
and they they I pretty much needed more
different voice on their show the assets
do on there and that was a remnant of
that particular podcast they had always
posted videos like that I kind of liked
the format even though I was in you know
earlier when I was kind of against it
because it took a lot of work of people
just submitting in video and then you
know one person would have to all
production as far as editing clipping
things together and things but I felt
like we can do this the easier way you
know if we were to do our own show
and so I just thought it it'll be a
great feature because usually when
you're watching podcasts you know it's
not like like with this one like
sometimes you just pop it on and you'll
do something else like you'd be another
browser reading something or watching
something else but it's like we wanted
people to stay engaged as far as the
chance I'm so having video there really
sometimes helped the kind of cuts the
attention span is so short so you know
having them multiple things people to
look at and do while they're listening
to your podcast is always great so we
just want to kind of keep that going
yeah that's good now with the with the
growth of that channel I know that Ella
said it's a couple of times to say that
you you guys are looking for guests to
come onto the show and that is the kind
of intermingle intermingle it have you
had any guests on there presently the
kind of stand out in your mind oh man I
think every guess we have on stand out
because I mean week to week is always
just the four of us so anytime we have a
guest it's like their voice is very
different from ours and it's always a
different perspective so it's hard for
me to say like pick out one person
that's it but I would say that we've
only had one recurring guest
I believe that's Martian cat I think she
was one of the lady that came onto the
show that I've done that kind of
multiple shows so yeah I was making the
game Awards right yeah yeah so it will
be her we've had a ton of great guys run
around the sticks
after you if you don't know who that is
um UX prophecy I think his name is got a
bunch of cool guests on there did are
they all memorable too like they're to
me those are the those are the very
entertaining yeah
the entertaining shows with the people
that kind of and you know they kind of
take those to show and put it on side
because you're going that they don't
they're not exactly the same view as you
but it's kind of it kind of works out
well because you know it's it's all
gaming and it's all good yeah and also
like the format kind of changes just so
slightly you know we of course we can
keep our same like intro then topics but
then you know we have a little segment
for the guest which is it just adds to
it yes yes King is in the chat by the
way and he says what's up he I just
wanted to make sure that you you know oh
yeah he's yeah he's give a shout outs
he's he is a busy man so for seeing them
in the chat we really appreciate you
stopping anyone thank you thank you so
so with with all with all the things
that you do now you said that you were
working on a on your YouTube channel
what what kind of progressed with that
and what did you end up going with that
what did you and you know kind of
explain your evolution with that Wow so
at the moment my youtube channel is kind
of dormant I mean like I said I when
2017 happened with all the you know
Microsoft going through all their studio
closures and things like that
um it was I was super like down and
bummed about it so my last video on my
last videos was the and again it was a
game I was super excited about was the
one with the dragon what was it called
great I was like no no it was a new game
that was slated to come out that was
councilman 2017
I'm not sure trust me that was I did a
video on a scale down like I was able to
find some new video that was released in
Japan I spliced it all together I talked
about the concept of multiplayer I even
gave these cool like community shots out
of then it was dope like I enjoyed that
was one small blast video pretty much
first and well first in depth in last
video because after that I was just I
had no more enthusiasm about doing
YouTube and the amount of work that
would go into and that's why people who
do YouTube videos I have so much respect
for them anybody who stream so much
respect because I know just how much
work go into all of it like the
production setup and then trying to keep
people engaged it's it's very um it's
very time intensive like it takes up a
lot of time and effort and so what I
with my with my stream schedule and kind
of what I do to produce content for my
YouTube page is and it's kind of a
little easier for me than others because
being on Twitch you can you can produce
markers throughout the whole entire time
you're streaming and I have an elgato
stream deck and I love the things so
every time something fun or exciting
happens I mark it
I mark it and you get a mega one like
the giant the giant you don't need it
you honestly do not need that giant that
you do no you don't because you can make
pages what
I ended up doing was I took my
programming mind and mentality and I
have it so I have my means my main
screen and I switch it to another screen
if I need to or if I should I have pages
for everything so you don't need
multiple ones two of them yes so but
what I ended up doing was I mark it and
then the next morning I'll end up
cutting all those all those markers and
then I'll end up saving them and
exporting them all to YouTube because I
want to produce content for my YouTube
page even if it's a little 5-10 minutes
gets right yeah the biggest thing is
consistency like that's what the ladies
that - when we were starting I said look
if we're not gonna be consistent I don't
want to do this guy know we had a couple
episodes or like early on like we would
do a show and then everybody got busy
and then we just do one show and then
two weeks ago but I'm like look we need
to be on here every week like without
fail whether it was one of us two of us
all of us like we need to just be
consistent what happened with us we
wanted to start gosh I couldn't even
tell you when was it September yeah
amber it was it was right the end of the
summer and everyone's schedules kind of
started conflicting and then L had to
move and MJ had to start school and it
was one of those things I was just like
man what am I gonna do and thankfully I
have a couple I had a couple of guests
kind of in Pocket that I knew that I can
kind of just call and be like yo I need
you on here can you help me out I got
nobody it's just gonna be you and me
will have some brews and we'll just talk
it out and they said yeah sure and they
would end up coming on when we were
ended up doing it one-on-one and it's
kind of it started the the process
because kind of get the the kinks out
and all the bugs you know if you if you
wanted to call them that from the first
couple of guests and now we kind of have
a more consistent schedule we're going
to have passed coming up so we're gonna
we might end up missing
couple but other than that kind of kind
of flowed very well and the works are
pretty pretty good so so so will you be
at e3 yes Amy - awesome
maybe I'll see you and I'll I think lol
are you doing I'm trying to go for sure
I got this mean ass old dog that I'm
trying to find somebody
she's like mean and old no that one was
jewy today he's ready to go for a walk
but he's cool like I asked my friend I'm
like you know so I'm trying to go to LA
and you know June and she's like well I
watched Chewie the other one Wow you
mean yeah wow I've never I've never
heard of a dog being that mean that
people like yeah because she likes
people so she's blind she's like going
deaf
she's old my wife's answer to all dogs
that are sad is I will hug them until
they're happy and it's like watching her
walk over to an animal that I'm just
like this is not safe what are you doing
and so far I'll bring you up to her it's
for me to go to e3 you guys are what
like four hours away we do not like
having dogs here because of the guinea
pigs
alright you know together to see kind of
get an idea where you are but I can't
even think any pace cut threw me off so
I don't me yeah you said four hours away
I'm like okay well where is this you
know by five and a half hours so I see
okay next to me she's giving me the evil
eye like you or am i hearing okay
can you let me know how it works out
we'll have to talk about that later
so back back a little little on topic
here so when you so what ends up which I
say is when you started you know playing
games and stuff and becoming you know
this this UI designer and all that what
like what was your was like your force
behind wine to do that
like whoa what was your passion for it
just because you grew up gaming or was
it just something that kind of evolved
into that or what was the reasons behind
it it's kind of a comma like you know
it's kind of a little bit of everything
um because like I mean I grew up I grew
up gaming mm-hmm but another part of it
was that I became fascinated with like
bringing something from like concept to
actually people using it so I've I've
always been in a creative space of like
whether it was doing you know logos for
people redesigning something for someone
so I've always been just I love that I
love creating and that's always been a
another you know at all the reason why I
wanted to become a programmer right was
because I always felt like making
something out of nothing nothing right
this is that's exactly it it's so
gratifying like just cuz you know you
pulled it from thin air like that's
that's that's it's for me that is
everything mm-hmm just concept release
go ahead I will say that when something
works you're like it's very gratifying
it can be very frustrating yeah and then
especially when you put like your your
time and effort into it and then all of
a sudden it clicks and it's like yo this
is this is amazing this I had this idea
there was nothing and now hundreds of
thousands of people are using this idea
that I created
and it's so good so I'm not I don't know
cuz I'm getting like emotional just
talking about and thinking about it cuz
it's just where my my passion like as
far as gaming though man look gaming
gaming saved my life like just being I
mean when I was in like high school and
dealing with like you know boyfriend
drama and such as such it was like
gaming was my escape from all of that
like you know if I need an outlet or
just a way to cope with what reality was
handing me or I just just jump into a
game and just disappear right so yeah
it's a I feel like it's like my life
like its worst no depression anything
like that was therapy so it's it's a
great escape for a lot of people to
handle you know their lives what's
happening with their lives I feel that
well she's a she's a therapist and
there's so many different types of
therapeutic ways for people to kind of
express themselves and I feel me coming
as an outsider not part of the whole
therapy thought process but as someone
looking in people being able to create
is a great therapeutic means and method
and gaming and creation of games is
another it's another way to do that
because they are they're using their
minds to put what they're doing on paper
right which is which is which is amazing
which is great so what was your first
gaming memory my first gaming memory was
Super Mario Brothers I had to be like I
was saying about four or five years old
and I just at that age I was just
fascinated that with the controller and
how like if I press a button on that
controller it will move on the screen I
was so blown away by that I remember
just looking
the controller pressing in looking at
the screen like constantly doing that
motion of like button and oh this moves
and I press this button in this move
like a mirror my MA like after a while
she would get like a little bit
frustrated cuz I want I want to play all
the time like all that time what didn't
didn't matter what was on the TV like I
always want to just take over and mess
around with the controller and stuff it
wasn't so much that I understood how to
play the game it was just that when I
press this this moves and when I you
know use this little light gun and I
shoot at these little ducks on screen
like they died in this little dog pops
up and laugh at you and know that you've
you know I mean if that you've missed
her and so it's just that that so my
first name in so after after you know
Nintendo like actually so fast me with
it I went back and I'm a friend down the
street had like an Atari and of course
they were that wasn't as cool it was
still interesting though interesting cuz
I remember playing like pitfall and
stuff like that but but yeah
it was it was Mario did you did you kind
of when you got your NES for the first
time and you kind of like looked at it
did you did you know of the impact it
was gonna have on your life or you just
thought of it was just like another toy
no I did I did not know I did not know
what kind of impact I have on my life I
discovered that probably when I got it
like later on once the newer systems
start releasing then I just knew every
Christmas all like oh what's the newest
games or what's the newest console i
yeah i didn't like then i didn't know
that it would be this big of a big of an
impact which is your favorite console of
all time
Wow oh I'd say 264 this is it for mm-hmm
that whole transition from 2d to 3d it
just it just it I knew that's what I
want to do like I'm like okay this this
is huge like it made me realize that
this is big this is bigger than me the
fact that you have this full 3d world
and you can navigate it
and like it was just it was just yeah it
was something else did you play
Goldeneye I did yeah did you have all
your friends come over and y'all play
and you just know it was it wasn't that
far I was one of the one of the only
families in my neighborhood to have like
a 64 mm console wasn't it wasn't like
that I couldn't have friends to have one
like but it was where kids would come
over just to see it and play it and then
try to take it from me because I was
always with the youngest one in the room
but um but that would be it yeah you'd
fight them off yeah I would try mm-hmm
you know I mean I got siblings too so we
all have to kind of share it and stuff
like that but how did you editor how did
your family kind of react to you wanting
to be in the you know the the gaming
sphere doing the doing the podcast and
the YouTube stuff and everything else
well at first it was like did they like
you need to turn the games off and don't
worry about him and just you know go to
school to be a doctor because that's
what I was studying I was studying - I'm
studying medicine when I graduated from
from high school and going to college
and then after taking a environmental
biology class I realized that man I hate
this like I don't want to study plants
like I want I'd rather study um you know
bodies human bodies was on that last
semester what the environmental biology
with the plants and yes hey hey but but
knowing that like that that validated it
for me it was like okay what's why am I
doing this when I know I love creating
why am I doing this well I know I love
technology and so I pivoted I mean I
told my parents that's like I'm I'm
changing I was so terrified you guys
have no idea how long I was saying I
wanted to go to school for medicine at
least from the time I was eight years
old all the way up until college I was
setting him
I was you know saying I want to go to
study medicine but when I came home one
of those things that you just do because
you feel like I was always great in my
studies you know I mean always had great
good grades and science I always loved
science and math so stem like that was
always my jam so when I got to college
it was like okay I'm still in this path
I still love science I'm still doing
this until that class that class was so
terrible and but but the teacher not
only was the teacher terrible but the
what I was studying I just didn't I
didn't like it cuz I hadn't ever studied
it before I think we've Dibble in
devilled in like grade school in high
school with it but never on this deep of
a level and I was like you know what
this is lame like if this is what I'm
gonna be doing I don't want to do it so
yeah after that class and I just went to
my advisor and I was like I'm changing
my major I can't I don't I don't think I
want to do this anymore I'm really like
I like we're tempting all just going and
by that point I was a little bit ahead
of the curve because I'd already been
teaching myself like how to create
websites and you know you know how to
create like stuff and paint it was I was
already doing some stuff that was you
know computer-based do they force you to
take a typing class in college no they
actually forces to take a type of
college I mean excuse me a typing class
in high school in college and I
literally walked over to my adviser and
I was like I'm not taking a typing class
and the person was like well you have to
I'm like a major in computer science why
would I need to take a class because I
know how to type did you take one in
high school though No
okay so you're just old yes I'm old
Walker and bengay diapers oh gosh let me
get my cranberry juice you know but yes
so I think the the advisors in college
they I'm sorry in college are easier to
persuade to how you want to go he wants
it to be like alright this is what I
want to be I feel like cool do this yeah
you pay for what you want to do if you
want to be here seven years because I
don't care but we'll make sure you're
doing it correctly you're absolutely
right so I think making that change at
it what a semester an extra semester but
it was worth it cuz I'm happy with how
everything you know turned out from that
decision well there cuz after that I was
able to like get an internship and then
like just really focus in on what I knew
it I'm like some sort of some students
can go through all of college you know
and then once they finish they still
know what they want to do I was
different like I knew exactly what I
want to do when I graduated and it was
so easy for me to be like okay my next
step is Exim and then my next step is
gonna be you know I was able to just
kind of you know pin out a path and try
to follow that trans actor it was just
straightforward basically probably a
better term to use this is where the old
person thoughts come in I lose my train
of thought but what I was gonna say was
with with college when when I ended up
going to college and taking the path for
computer science they were like we have
software development we have networking
we have design and it's all under the
information systems technology field so
I was like so I signed up for soft
development as my major but when I get
my actual degree and you look at my
degree it's just gonna say information
could be or science and they're like
yeah so I'm like alright well does my do
I have enough qualifications for my for
my networking degree and they're like
yeah I'm like let's just change to that
and so I can graduate so I feel like we
live is the time that we're living in
now is so special you literally can
learn anything you need right like on
the internet like everything's so
accessible people what's your hardest
part about your job but I'm like
figuring out the right way how to type
in Google what I'm looking for
that is my hardest part of my day trying
to Google the correct answer if you had
the type of class you never know that's
kind of like when I was in college I
mean I did I did the kind of similar
thing cuz I felt like I had already
taught myself so much weight as far as
you know web design great you know
creating websites that's where my major
I didn't major in it it was it was
definitely kind of in the easier route
like let me just take web development I
know it already I just make sure days no
I really wanted to like I wanted to
learn something completely different so
I did what you did like I did the
networking thing learning about routers
routers and switches and stuff like that
which was it was weird be in those
classrooms because you know being being
a minority you know the black won't only
black woman in a class felt a little
awkward but it kind of prepped me for
the industry that I'm that I'm in today
you know I'm sorry no there's not is
there many what was like your favorite
class then my favorite class it wasn't
the development class it was the Java it
was they were teaching job at the time
but that was it it clicked you know that
was it for me
it's like Java man yeah um my java
professor I I was gonna kill him because
like he's like this is all theory and
I'm like cool show me on the board what
theory you're talking about cuz hey you
are just seeing
with no examples and I don't understand
what you're saying and then he would
he'd be like come to my office and
office hours I'm like I don't have time
for that just and then then he would
write it on the board and then I would
understand it and a bit cool but uh man
that class drive me nuts
I'm sorry that was my one cry for like
you didn't like oh man yeah I had a
fantastic teacher and I was so sad cuz I
found out later after I had graduated
and like moved on and my critics yet
actually she died from cancer oh yeah I
was like this lady don't know how much
she impacted my life like you know it's
just things perspective for you
sometimes it's like wow you just never
know just how things are gonna go and I
mean sometimes you know that's why I say
be kind people man be nice you know
who's gonna be your boss you never know
who's gonna end up you know helping you
with something later on down a road just
like just be kind and just just live
like sorry get emotional here but I'm
gonna change real quick MJ you got
anything um nothing much really already
pretty much said everything earlier I
think I had but I know I wanted to say
that yeah I gotta have you show me
better because I know it's not hard but
I had the worst teachers like yeah big
the one teacher it was like oh watch
this guy from San Diego State I'm like
so watch another professor that's Wow
yeah sometimes after it's my argument
with my Java t-shirt he goes hey I have
a great thing for you and I'm like
what's that he goes we need someone to
chew or Java in Visual Basic can you you
want to do that and I'm like sure and I
was just like I've had all these
arguments with the student with this
teacher about Java and he wants me to
tutor other students
it didn't make any sense whatsoever but
I ended up doing it was probably one of
the best times of college because it was
like you were teaching your other
classmates like how they were doing
things wrong yeah I would say the advice
I can give would be to as far as Java
like if you really want to use my god
I would I did Java back then but I
wouldn't pick select Java now I mean
because it's just so many other they
still know it's the base you know it's
like the granddaddy of all of majority
of it's not all of it because you got
Perl and COBOL not even go shop is good
too
it's basically you have the base
language and it's just pulling modules
right other other groupings it's it's
not even it's not even like you have to
know what you're doing anymore let's
just call this call that call this call
that and then put this in here and then
put this in here and you know put this
in the space they changed I feel like
they've changed programming and involved
it so much that you can actually
minimize your knowledge of it because
like Java you know it's like the base
for every other language like if you
learned Java you can learn c-sharp you
can learn angular you can learn you can
learn anyone any programming language
and that's why most colleges teach it
because it at some point it's just the
syntax is different same concepts just
different way you taught you put on
screen so guys it's so many I mean you
could use if you really want to like
learn on your own and this is anybody
you could use like udemy courses they
got and they're really cheap sometimes
you can get them for like $10 for the
entire course and learn at your own pace
there's so many tools today that that
man it's just it's super easy to if your
very first professor or somebody who's
ever teaching you is pure just trash and
you can't yo just mmm just you know
sometime you gotta just try to take it
take it into your own hands and and you
know try to fight for your
your knowledge and learning I guess on
the house of work but L did you have any
more questions no I think yeah you've
got one final question which is
confusing to everyone and then after
that we'll do our outros but so I'll we
what I like to ask everyone that's like
the last question before before we head
off on the show of the show is if you
could live in any environment fantasy
environment what would it be it could be
any fantasy environment from books video
games to you no comment books any
anything what would you where would you
want to be okay so I think a you so
would you like to live in the world of
harry potter luck with wizard universe
or Star Wars or you know or anything
like the time of like Lord of the Rings
things like that any of those worlds I'm
just throwing out random stuff you can
pick literally anything
we've had people say that they want to
live in the land of like Viva was like
Viva Pinata the land of pokemons is an
interesting question um Wow you know
honestly I've never really thought about
like oh I want to be in that world such
um cuz usually when you play games is
like it's dystopian in there or it's
it's you know post-apocalyptic it
doesn't have to be games you could be
like I'll I don't want to be in any of
those I want to be on the beach in
Bermuda picks up the futuristic even
though like I have this weird thing with
technology like I wanted to advance but
I don't want people to lose their jobs
in the process which is it's this whole
automated world we're going toward it's
just that's one of the conversation um I
was
say that's because I think the game is
gonna be super cool I would say it would
be set up on 2077 that that world looks
pretty neat I can mark myself which was
super cool abilities and whatnot so you
remember the show right on Syfy yeah
what show it was like a show that was
like cyberpunk like 20 so really great
no but I would pick I would pick yeah
something futuristic like was it a Fifth
Element like that was dope doesn't the
world because it was for me with element
was kind of me because it was it was
still it was futuristic but it was like
you still had some kind of standards
type things because when they were in
the theater you they're still sitting in
a regular theater and they still
watching this lady perform it was just
like okay it's not too far out there
because I got in I never thought of like
the fifth element as a as a type of
world or environment because there
really really was no Warsh
to other than them trying to you know
save the world but that's pretty good
you know pretty good thought I liked it
I liked it so so it's a while why don't
you tell us you know wherever we can
find you and what you know everything
all your all your plugs if you wear the
gwg ladies are and all that yeah sure oh
well you guys everyone listening or in
the chat or you know anywhere you guys
know you can follow me on Twitter at
Delilah underscore HD can also catch me
on growing gaming on Saturdays at noon
eastern nine Pacific yeah at youtube.com
for slash grown women gaming and Twitter
like it cuz I I do these xbox win
campaigns
all of my own this is even before
Microsoft and all that stuff it's like I
just try to give something away and just
I try to encourage people to participate
in those because it's just fun for me
mostly but but yes so that the hashtag
is just hashtag Xbox WI in hi Xbox win
and it just stands for Xbox and Windows
10 you know obvious reasons now I guess
those are your personal giveaways that
you're giving back to yes all personal
I'm not getting is like hashtag no
endorsements no ads ologists me giving
crap away because I just I just like to
I just remember what it's like to win
stuff and it's just it's my way of just
giving back to the community that the
community has helped me you know in my
growth and helped me you know obtain the
comfortable style that I have now in my
life so I like to give every way as much
as I can when I can you hear that guy
she's comfortable that's great I I think
that everyone should I should go in
there and take care of that and I'll
I'll try to put some links in to you
know our our comments below and also
into the into the podcast information
when we go through that MJ good sir you
can find me on twitter at bay DM j you
can find me on snapchat feed 101 you
just recently hit let's see here it'll
load I think I'm at like four hundred
and thirty thousand snaps shots nananana
it's it's great it's great I applaud you
for being able to do the snapchats
because I am confused and I'm an old
person which we've established that in
this episode that I will not be using
snapchat snapchat tik-tok all of those
are like wow I guess I mean you know
that's right
you say well know your limits right yeah
I guess yeah have two more parts of
people that do that cuz I can't I'm
always like I don't you know I'll be on
camera when I'm with necessary I just
I'm like I try to avoid it I don't want
my information out there I'm super
particular about it so I don't know I
mean maybe one day I'll be like okay I'm
gonna get this I'm gonna get this
Instagram going I'm gonna get yeah it's
just not today
right now it's I kind of agree with you
like I thought about being more private
and then I thought to myself what's the
point if I'm streaming to the internet
every night I was like there's no
there's no point for being private
because everyone everyone kind of knows
my business already as it is
I mean yeah that's truly everybody knows
everything already yeah so it's like if
it's super personal no one's gonna hear
it
the only people are gonna know about it
it's myself and my wife that's it and
then everybody else is getting nothing
anyway l work we find you a boogie oh
208 or mixer and on Twitter a mixer
Tuesday and Friday set P 7 p.m. to 9
p.m. going strong there and yeah
oh yeah people like reminds me anyways
she's on Saturday mornings and then here
next week on Monday yes she is in both
places and you know you see that we're
here he gave the black people no brakes
on him located he knows I love him if I
didn't he wouldn't get these jokes
understand these jokes no no I mean like
I just wouldn't joke with you drinks on
me next time okay on to that - can we
get a drink for me because I won't be
there so so we can get you out of here
so you can get your movie yeah husband
already takes me twice that's an a why
do you can check me out on instagram
twitter and twitch I am on twitch on
from everyday Monday to Friday the 7:00
to 10:00 unless I am here Morse I've
actually been streaming a little bit on
the weekends also because my wife is at
work so I'm what am I gonna do I'm gonna
play video games it's it's a known thing
that happens all the time
so keep an eye on my on my on my Twitter
for anything that goes on and what's new
and make sure you guys are you know what
is it gonna say again discord I'm on
this court if anybody needs anything any
questions anything like that we're gonna
we're going to probably start having
some of our writers from lords of gaming
net on for the next couple of weeks
before we get to PAX East cuz I want
everybody to know who these guys are
before we end up getting there and you
start seeing their faces and asking who
are these people I have no idea where
they are that were that are part of the
iron loads podcast team so I definitely
we're gonna start to see that if anyone
has any questions please email us at
roundtable stream team at gmail.com we
are on twitter as table stream if you go
ahead and hit that follow button you'll
get notifications on who's our guest
when we are going live and any fun
things that are going on if you need
anything you know you can always you
know add us there and I'll try to get
back to you we are on iTunes Spotify and
all that fun stuff Wednesday mornings it
will be coming out and we'll come up
live I'll try to splice the videos up
because of our Internet
shoes from before I'll see what I can do
and just remember the iron ghost podcast
is on on Sundays at 1:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time go check those guys out
there fantastic crew that that we work
with and thank you everyone that are the
viewers are checking us out tonight I
greatly appreciate you guys coming in
and you know I love seeing that that
live chat goin it's awesome and thank
you everyone and remember to dream big
and keep gaming and we'll see everybody
next week all right
he's my everybody